be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
it's still continuing our discussion on
the lead-up to Civil War two what I want
to do here is have a discussion about
the Cosmic Cube and what I'm hoping is
that at the end of this video you'll
have a strong understanding of how the
cube works as well as how it ties into
the events of Civil War two
so the Cosmic Cube first appeared in
1966 with tails us as fans issue number
79 and was first created by Stan Lee as
a plot device in a story involving the
group aim otherwise known as advanced
idea mechanics to sidetrack for a second
because aim as it was originally created
served to be a general enemy of the
Marvel Universe throughout the stories
involving the Fantastic Four Captain
America the Avengers and Iron Men this
combined with Marvel quite literally
throwing out a hodgepodge of content to
see what stuck during their explosion of
popularity in the 1960s mended the
Cosmic Cube was created as a means to
tie into the overarching themes of both
magic and heroism as a result the cube
was depicted as being capable of
granting the wishes of its possessor
regardless of how that which violated or
complimented the laws of physics but
following these first initial
appearances the cube largely fell into
the background of Marvel as an
on-again-off-again plot device in truth
the Cosmic Cube did not actually become
a serious object worthy of indebt
storytelling until 1969 when it appeared
in a five-year long story running
through Captain America daredevil
Captain Marvel and marvel two and one
centering on marvel of the Kree leading
the heroes of Earth in an effort to stop
Thanos from using the cube to blink out
all the stars in existence as a means to
destroy the life within their solar
systems and impress misters death much
like his original appearance the cube
was not given an origin or basis behind
his abilities instead the writings of
Stan Lee Steve Gerber and others relied
on previously existing information to
establish the significance of the cube
and the danger it posed in the wrong
hands as a result and going into the
next several years the Cosmic Cube took
a back seat yet again appearing
occasionally in the form of advanced
idea mechanics creating a second cube as
well as various other villains creating
cubes of their own including red skull
the scrolls and Doctor Doom in addition
to this 1983 is Captain America annual
number seven by writer Peter Gilles
wrapped up the initial path threads of
the first cosmic cube by establishing
that the cubes themselves were sentient
to determine who could use them and how
with the first Cosmic Cube evolving into
a being named cubic who possess powers
with no definite limit however following
the 1984 story of Secret Wars and it's
1985 sequel Secret Wars to where Marvel
had intended to launch a third iteration
of the event due to both its popularity
among readers as well as his popularity
in relation to the development of toy
products because plans for the sequel
ultimately fell through for reasons that
I've not been able to locate under
writer Steve Englehart this story was
confined to issue number 319 of the
Fantastic Four wrapping the molecule man
Owen Reese the original beyonder from
the first and second secret wars and the
Cosmic Cube together into a single fold
and detailing an origin for how the
cubes came into existence as it's
explained when molecule man's powers
manifested as a result of his initial
experiment covered in my video on Owen
Reese explained how portal was twin open
to another dimension
containing a series of pockets that has
vast energies the various energies had
been put there by a race called the
beyonders that existed outside all known
space and time now why these energies
replace in this dimension was never
actually explained and still remained
somewhat of a mystery within the realm
of Marvel but regardless of their
intentions the various cosmic cubes
created over the course of the
universe's history came out of the
process that came with capturing these
energies into a tesseract of sorts which
usually took the form of a cube due to
its energetic distribution to this in
Owen Reese was granted his abilities
when a portal to the pocket of energy
was opened and no containment cube was
available to harness it
meaning that half the energy entered
Owen Reese allowing him to manipulate
the very fabric of reality with the
other half taking the form of the
original Beyonder from the first secret
wars who possessed equal power for this
particular bit of history allowed Marvel
and Englehart to wrap up almost all
loose ends which included retconning the
power of molecule man and introducing a
new being named cosmos as a sentient
Cosmic Cube with writer jim Starlin
having effectively taken over Marvel's
cosmic opera by focusing on the stories
of Thanos Adam warlock in the cosmic
entities the Cosmic Cube almost
disappeared from existence to be
replaced with the Infinity stones now to
offer a bit of a comparison here and
this may be a topic worthy of a video in
and of itself Marvel had never actually
offered an answer to the debate of
whether or not the Cosmic Cube Trump's
the Infinity stones this is compounded
by the
like that the cube had no involvement of
any kind in the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline and the only information I've
been able to locate on how the two
concepts compared to one another takes
place in the Infinity Crusade crossover
coming out of infinity war which
followed up to the Infinity Gauntlet and
focus on Magus Adam warlocks evil
persona harnessing different cosmic
cubes from the round the multiverse and
eventually secure the Infinity Gauntlet
for himself infinity Crusade focused on
Adam warlocks purely good have referred
to as goddess looking to solve a problem
of evil in the universe but only looking
at solutions that existed in the
extremes while the goddess was defeated
through the combined efforts of Adam
warlock Thanos and Charles Xavier
during the crossover the demon entity
Mephisto was questioned about the cubes
origins rehashing the information
provided in Fantastic Four issue number
319 Mephisto one step further arguing
that the cubes themselves had the
potential to rival the Infinity stones
and power however because his comparison
is never officially made again within
the comic landscape on the whole fans
are usually left to their own
interpretations but because the Infinity
Gauntlet had been used in a much grander
scale including Thanos wiping out half a
life in the universe as well as the
Infinity stones being consistently
referred to as the most dangerous and
powerful artifacts in the universe it
can be assumed that the stones exist on
a higher level of capability than the
cubed now following this with the
Infinity Gauntlet at the forefront of
models most powerful artifacts as well
as a fantastic force exploits
highlighting the abilities of the
ultimate nullifier the Cosmic Cube began
to become less and less important
serving as a literal retconning machine
as an example with michael korvac having
appeared in 1978 as an enemy of the
original guardians of the galaxy and
thor in the 31st century the first
corvax saga
Underwriters Jim shooter and magis
turned the saw core back stealing the
power of Galactus in the 31st century
and traveling into the past while being
pursued by the original guardians of the
galaxy who teamed up with the
present-day Avengers with a core back
rocket did conclude with corvax suicide
Jim Valentino's 1991 story and guardians
of the galaxy annual number one sock or
vac return albeit depowered reopening
plot threads that were left hanging at
the storage conclusion using the Cosmic
Cube as a means to eliminate Michael
Kovak in his entirety under writer Mark
Waid the cosmic queue was invoked in
Captain
Volume three issues 14 through 19 which
depicted Captain America and Red Skull
working together to eliminate Kovac
using the Cosmic Cube as it was presents
and absorbed by the Red Skull himself
now following this as far as I've been
able to tell between 1999 and 2005 the
Cosmic Cube had disappeared from the
Marvel landscape entirely now whether
this was due to editor-in-chief Joe
Quesada viewing it as a none essential
part of his 10-year long vision to
restore Marvel to its classic routes or
because no one bothered to use it is a
question I don't have the answer to but
with writer Ed Brubaker coming on as
writer for Captain America vol 5 the
Cosmic Cube we use as an integral part
of his redcon of Captain America's
history where much of this information
can be found in my video on Bucky Barnes
explained because the work of Brubaker
saw Bucky Barnes returned to the Marvel
landscape after almost 50 years of being
absent his return came as the Winter
Soldier having been exposed to the
Russian super soldier program which
included a combination of gene therapy
and behavior modification while the
contents of Roo Baker's run stretched
the entirety of House of M decimation
and it lead up to civil war at the
story's conclusion
Captain America used the cube to restore
Bucky's memories of his past life
sending Barnes into a mental and
emotional crisis allowing his character
to remain absent throughout the entirety
of civil war now following this between
2006 going into the launch of Secret
Wars and the start of all-new
all-different marvel in 2015 the cosmic
you made a handful of minor appearances
which included falling into the hands of
star-lord Peter quill and crusher creel
the absorbing man that said with a
venture standoff seeing the first
appearance of Bucky Barnes an all-new
all-different marvel as well as being
Marvel's first major crossover following
the relaunch standoff ran through all of
the Avengers titles the Illuminati and
Sam Wilson solo series as well as Howlin
commandoes
and detailed the goings-on of Pleasant
Hill a prison complex created by shield
for the purpose of reconditioning
supervillains created by Nick Spencer
Mark Bagley and Luke Ross the events
within Stan ba fell as a combination of
prison 42 from Civil War and the
formation of the Beyonder during the
first secret wars and at shield have
been rounding up fragments of cosmic
tubes and tuning to use them as a means
to safeguard the earth from both local
and foreign threats however the concept
of the cubes containing some measure of
sentience came to fruition when the
fragments merged into a being named
Kovac
which took the form of
young girl with omnipotent powers who
sought out Red Skull due to Schmidt
having previously been merged with the
cube himself subbing in part as a way to
fold Erik Selvig from the MCU over into
the comics the events of Pleasant Hill
unfolded with Barron helm use emo
leading a revolt against shield taking
over the town and forcing the Avengers
to respond where the Avengers were
successful in quelling the revolt Bucky
Barnes Kovac and a handful of other
villains were whirled over into the
newest incarnation of the Thunderbolts
finding alongside Bucky Barnes and is
ever to safeguard the earth as the man
on the wall following this the Cosmic
Cube returned to being a background
concept leading into civil war - and
that with Thanos having escaped his
imprisonment in the nothingness outside
of all known space and time his arrival
in the Marvel Comrie allottee came with
the realization that shield was in
possession of a Cosmic Cube continue to
use the cube as a means to continuous
campaign in wiping out all things in
existence the lead-up to Civil War 2
came in the form of the inhuman Ulysses
having a premonition of Thanos has
returned prompting the Avengers of The
Ultimates and various other heroes to
assemble leading to a battle against
Thanos that resulted in the death of
James Rhodes and the near-fatal injuries
of she-hulk
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later peace